in this video you're going to learn to
build adamantium bones just like
Wolverine to turn your legs and your
arms into blades which is useful if ever
because what's just awesome all right
actually there's a lot of very good
reasons to build strong bones not only
is it important as you get older to
prevent injury but it's also very
important if you hit the gym often if
you're an athlete in order to prevent
injuries that can cause time off of the
gym and make you lose your gains
let's bone let's do this so the human
body is changing all the time it's
constantly growing and adapting that's
non-negotiable the only thing that you
get to decide is whether it's getting
stronger or getting weaker and this is
true of the bones as well there's a
common misconception that bones are
these kind of inert rods in our bodies
that never change their lifetimes when
actually this is living tissue just like
your muscle and it's changing all the
time in fact you'll sometimes hear bones
referred to as a kind of bank or
repository for calcium and other
minerals so basically this is a store
that your body can draw on when blood
calcium gets low and this process is
carried out by cells called osteoclasts
which burrow into the bone and absorb
the calcium back into the blood feed to
use this is a completely normal process
that happens all the time
and of course if bone can be broken down
it can also be built back up and
restored otherwise it would just
dissolve and you'd be an empty sack of
blood and meat so this is handled by
osteoblasts which are cells which repair
they lay down bone matrix and this is
mineralized to increase your bone
density this happens all the time in
response to general activity as well as
in response to certain exercise which
causes micro damage so just like when
you train the muscles and you create
micro damage micro tears and the muscle
fiber you can also create micro damage
in the bones and this again gets built
back stronger
so actually have a bone metabolism which
handles this process which itself is
called bone remodeling it happens all
the time in fact every ten years
your entire skeleton is completely
replaced so we want to create micro
damage and the good news is that if you
already go to the gym then you already
doing this on a regular basis and
best types of exercise to cause enough
stress in the bones to increase bone
density our weight-bearing exercises so
anything where you're holding a large
amount of weight on your shoulders or
pressing a large amount of weight
basically your compound moves and
anything with high impact so anything
where there's a large weight a large
force going through the bones or a jolt
going through the bones so squats bench
press all your compound movements
they're really good for building up bone
density likewise a 2 or your plyometric
exercises that means things like
clapping press ups or depth jumps box
jumps anything with an explosive
component will create enough shock
through the joints and the bones to
create that tiny bit of micro damage
that you need to then encourage an
increase in bone density of course it
got to be very careful here with your
joints and make sure you using correct
biomechanics otherwise you can create
the wrong kind of stress on your bones
likewise sprinting is really good and
actually studies show that sprinters
have significantly greater bone density
as compared with long-distance runners
because of course it's more high-impact
again you need to make sure that your
gait is correct you need to make sure
that you're wearing the right Footwear
so don't just go and pound the tarmac
thinking it's good for you it is good
for your bones but it might not be good
for your joints you need to do it
correctly and likewise skipping is
something you can do at home that will
increase your bone density again by
giving you that little bit of shock and
impact but if you're already lifting
heavy weights with squats and deadlifts
and bench press and if you're already
doing plyometric exercises then you've
got a very good start and we can also
create micro damage to the surface of
the bones by directly impacting on them
this is what my Thai fighters do when
they strike against trees in order to
not only give themselves tougher and
thicker knuckles but also harder and
more desensitized shins so you can
incorporate this into your training if
you really want to by kicking against a
heavy bag with your shins or hitting the
heavy bag with without gloves but be
gentle
especially to begin with in order to
gradually build up the toughness in your
hands and your shins and this is
actually a really important thing if you
are a trained fighter because in a lot
of real fights one of the biggest
problems is that when you hit someone
the knuckles will break or at least
you're really badly hurt and bruised
your hands so building up the toughness
the fist is actually one of the most
practical things you can do as a fighter
another thing you can do is to try
rolling bamboo sticks up and down your
shins and this will not only create a
small amount of micro damage and a very
controlled manner but it'll also help
you to desensitize the very sensitive
nerves that live along the shins this is
something my granddad used to get me to
do I had a unusual childhood at times
and then of course there's iron palm
training which is used by Shaolin monks
and Wing Chun practitioners it's another
form of conditioning for the hands and
the palms which involves hitting them
against sandbags and buckets of ice and
increasing the grip training and doing
finger push-ups and all this hardens the
bones and also the strength of the hands
and the wrists in order to turn them
into more formidable weapons and of
course at this point once your knuckles
start bulging we are starting to get
into Wolverine territory and after all
these strikes and hits against the hands
then I apply an ointment called a deep
dark ow which is a concoction of herbs
said to help aid to the healing and
encourage circulation reduce swelling
and I'm not going to get into that now
because there's lots of different
potential recipes and tons and tons of
potential ingredients and they're all
variable in terms of their scientific
verify ability but this is what they do
anyways if you want to incorporate
something similar into your training I
don't recommend that you start smashing
your hands against things but what you
can do is gently try punching a phone
book or a large book of some sort or
wrapping your knuckles against it
another opportunistically knuckle press
ups on a wooden floor or a stone or
laminate floor which hurts at first but
over time you'll grow the strength and
the knuckles you can actually see them
increase in size we seduce at karate
training a guy called master ho shows
just how far you can take this he has an
invincible finger ladies he was on Stan
Lee's superhumans and they demonstrated
help by jabbing it into things
repeatedly he managed to build up the
strength of the bone to the point that
he could use it to burst open
watermelons just by jabbing his finger
straight into it and it's become you
know a pretty deadly weapon he can't use
for much else I don't recommend anyone
else take it to this degree but it just
goes to show how much potential there is
for the bones to grow and strengthen and
adapt to training if he's able to
generate that kind of force and get
through that coconut with his finger
he's basically taking the force of a
boxer's punched right through the index
finger and focusing all that load just
on the tip of his finger wow that sounds
serious
so yeah if you want to strengthen your
bones than you need to be doing heavy
compound lifts plyometric explosive
exercises and then potentially if you
want to take it a step further you can
try kicking your shins against punch
bags you can try hitting the punch bag
lightly at first without gloves you can
drive performing knuckle push-ups you
can use mild
iron palm training it goes without
saying that of course that need to be
really careful with all of these things
because if you shatter your bones then
you're not Wolverine but of course it's
not just a matter of breaking down bone
and causing damage what's also very
important is rebuilding it and restoring
it just as with muscle training it's a
biphasic process so how do we make sure
that after we've caused that micro
damage that the bones are then going to
come back thicker and stronger as much
as possible well first of all nutrition
is highly important you probably know
that calcium is crucial for bone health
however this doesn't mean that you
should just go out there and eat tons
and tons of calcium because there is an
upper limit to how much you can benefit
from as long as you within the
recommended range races 1,000 to 2,000
milligrams then you're going to be okay
and if you exceed this it can actually
have negative health effects you can get
calcium from milk from water mineral
water and from a whole load of green
vegetables there are some people that
think milk isn't good for calcium they
say that you can't absorb it they say
that it leeches calcium from the bones
which isn't true these the science
doesn't back this up the research
suggests that milk is perfectly fine
Dairy is perfectly fine as long as
you're not lactose intolerant and I'm
not gonna go into it into more depth
here but if you want to read more about
that click the link down below to head
over to the full article and also a link
to another interesting article from
marks daily Apple which is a really good
website and he talks about this and
links
of interesting studies if you're
interested but of course if you don't
believe me and you prefer not to take
milk that's absolutely fine there's
plenty of other places that you can get
calcium from we also know that magnesium
is highly important of course and
vitamin D which helps to absorb calcium
the best way to get more vitamin D is to
spend time outdoors and if you spend all
your time indoors then you get a whole
host of bone problems which demonstrates
just how important getting more sunlight
is so try and be more active try and be
outside more you'll have a ton of other
benefits as well
protein and particularly animal protein
has been shown to be important for bone
health likewise it seems that probiotics
can be effective for restoring and
strengthening the bones and there's also
some evidence to suggest that
inflammation is bad for your bone health
so getting more omega-3 in your diet
could help to support bone strength as
well all of the steroid hormones that
means testosterone estrogen DHT things
like growth hormone will help to build
stronger bones as well and in fact this
is one of the medicinal legal uses of
anabolic steroids it's given to people
with weak and brittle bones in order to
build them up thicker and stronger
there's lots of ways you can support a
healthy and normal hormone balance
getting more sleep getting more sunlight
getting healthy saturated fats because
these hormones are created from
cholesterol so I won't go into that in
detail here but again I'll leave a link
in the description down below on how to
increase testosterone healthily and
naturally what's perhaps more surprising
is that melatonin is also very important
for bone health melatonin being the
sleep hormone not only because when you
sleep you produce more of these other
anabolic hormones and repair damage that
you've caused during the day but also
because melatonin itself seems to be
linked with bone strength and there's
studies suggesting that if you don't
have enough melatonin then your bones
become more weaker so this is another
reason to avoid blue light at nighttime
and to make sure you're getting lots and
lots of good quality sleep then there
are hormones that directly control and
regulate bone metabolism things like
power thyroid hormone which encourages
the osteoclasts to break down the bone
tissue in order to release the minerals
into the blood and more amazing still is
that the bones themselves appear to also
release hormones into the body so for
instance lipo Callan or lipo calendar
- is a hormone released by the bones to
say that they've had enough minerals
from your diet and this acts as an
appetite suppressant so just as your
stomach can send signals back to your
brain to say that it's full so - can
your bones release signals interpreted
by your brain to suppress your appetite
so it just goes to show how incredibly
complex our bodies are even the bones
are actually speaking to our brains and
can play a role in things like weight
gain other hormones produced by the
bones or by aspects of the bone
metabolism can control our energy
metabolism and have all kinds of other
effects on our health so sclerostin for
instance is produced in order to trigger
the release of osteoblasts and this can
increase insulin sensitivity then you've
got calcine osteocalcin rather which is
produced by the osteoblasts and this can
help switch the body to a ketogenic
state when we're low on carbs allowing
it to burn fat for fuel so yes the bones
are super complex and it really isn't
our best interest to look after them
so looking after your hormone balance
and getting lots of sleep and causing
this micro damage and getting tons of
minerals will increase the density of
your bones because more those minerals
will be incorporated into this formation
of the bone making it stronger but
actually a lot of the strength of the
bone comes not from it being solid and
hard but from it being bendy and
adaptable so actually your bones a
they're hollow they're not solid they of
course have the bone marrow Center but
at the same time the bone itself the
mineral aspect uses a honeycomb
structure which is designed in order to
absorb impact and the amount of impact
that the bones can absorb is incredible
even when you're just jumping and
running you're taking an impact that's
several times greater than your own body
weight and there have been stories of
people falling out of planes and
surviving the landing without breaking a
single bone partly this was because they
landed well they landed on the side of a
hill on a steep gradient or they landed
in a haystack but it's still incredible
and it's because the bones are able to
absorb that impact and Bend that's what
they're designed to do and shaken
horrific aliy his limp body drops out of
the sky
a quarter of a mile away they're not
supposed to be rigid and brittle they're
supposed to be bendy like the willow
tree that blows in the wind rather than
the oak that gets blown over
pound for pound bond is stronger than
concrete
it has a strength to weight ratio found
in no other natural material on earth
but astonishingly almost half of our
bone mass is soft and alive allowing our
bones to bend
so the question you might be wondering
is why doesn't this always happen why is
it that someone can fall out of a plane
and not break any bones but you can trip
over and break your arm
and part of the answer is that these
people who survived the fall from planes
they invariably tend to faint or pass
out and this allows them to go limp and
lets the bone do its job whereas
normally we tense up when we're
expecting an impact from the brace and
what this does is it prevents the bones
from moving properly holds them in place
applies forces to them already so then
when we take the impact we're much more
likely to cause serious damage so
actually the very best thing you can do
if you're falling or if you get punched
is to go limp and to go with it because
that way your bones should absorb more
of the impact at the same time of course
it makes sense to increase your
flexibility as much as possible that way
you increase your range of motion and
also you reduce the usual reflex to
shorten muscle as it elongates and
instead you'll allow it to move further
without fighting it and this in theory
means that if you trip or fall or if you
move in an awkward way you'll be less
likely to tense up and snap something or
strain something and finally make sure
you're getting lots of collagen in your
diet
collagen actually is responsible for
making up a large amount of the bone as
well as minerals and it's responsible
for the tensile strength of your bone so
its ability to be pulled and stretched
and also for its elasticity and it helps
to make it more springy and spongy
rather than just tough and dense if you
didn't have any collagen in your diet
then if your bones would be hard but far
more likely to break you can get
collagen in your diet by eating more
gelatin or by eating things like bone
broth which is highly popular right now
it's got lots of health benefits it's
very trendy so there you go that's a
recipe for stronger bones like Wolverine
you need to be strengthening your bones
by increasing the load and the pressure
by doing plyometric exercises by
sprinting and skipping by lifting heavy
weight with compound movements at the
same time you can damage the surface of
the bones in order to make them harder
and stronger like blades if you want
using iron palm training kicking against
trees if you're kind of crazy at the
same time you need to make sure you're
getting plenty of sleep need to look at
your hormone balance eat lots of
minerals lots of green vegetables dairy
products and you need to increase your
flexibility and eat lots of collagen if
you do all those things then your bones
will be strong and healthy get outside a
lot as well your bones will be strong
and healthy and you shouldn't have any
breaks and if you punch someone it's
gonna hurt a lot more because your bones
will be hard and your fists wouldn't
explode into splinters don't punch
people
so thanks time for watching guys hope
fans were useful interesting if you did
then please leave a like please share it
around that helps me immensely leave a
comment down below and let me know what
you thought or hit me up on social media
you can find me on Facebook on Instagram
on Twitter and the links in the
description down below subscribe to the
channel if you want more like this hit
the bell button if you want
notifications and stay tuned for more
videos on body building strength
training parkour martial arts
productivity technology biohacking
nootropics working online all that usual
stuff if that sounds good then thanks a
ton for watching and bye for now